you're watching twice coming up on this
week's show a peek under the bonnet we
see how a racing game is Mays Queen
guitarist Brian May tells me how he's
been taking on the virtual reality craze
with a Victorian way of seeing things
and Sony finally reveals its new
consoles welcome to swipe this week
we've been given behind-the-scenes
access at a major racing video games
maker this is where the Forza horizon
franchise is made a series of car racing
titles that have sold by the million
around the world and Chris has been
finding out exactly what's involved in
making the game's high octane thrills of
racing video games or what makes them
popular but the developers of this title
are putting as much effort into the
world around the cars as they are the
vehicles themselves the team behind
Forza horizon 3 spent months in
Australia where the game is set
capturing footage of the sky
they took over 2 million photos which
they used in-game meaning the sky you
see when you play is real rather than
CGI on previous titles it was a very
simple process where you put an image
onto a background and that was your sky
felt that wasn't realistic enough for us
so we want to disguise actually like the
world and the cars the lighting in the
environment is the largest thing that
everyone sees everything fits everything
it brings everything to life and gives
everything a real authentic feel of
course that's not to say the detail on
the actual cars is neglected once we
identify which car we like to make we'll
send a photographer and they'll take
2,000 pictures will then study those
photographs and we'll start building the
a certain stage 3 studio max in the game
you can see which classes they finished
a set you can see that again attention
to detail is is paramount
another important part of the game is
sound and it isn't just the engine
noises the developers even captured
audio of carved damage a lot of time
effort and money goes into making titles
like this and support from the
government is an important part of that
the tax credits legislation has recently
come through has been a massive shot in
the arm for all UK developers making
games here it's certainly very
beneficial in terms of building a game
without you know a British origin our
team of British were obviously based
exclusively here in the UK and it
certainly incentivizes exactly that
happening things don't always go so well
though earlier this year
Cheshire based developer evolution
Studios also known for its racing games
closed down that's despite its most
recent title Drive clubs surpassing 2
million sales the British games industry
is a competitive market so it's clear
that companies need to innovate if they
want to stay in the race
Chris Creegan Sky News stay with us
still so calm I'll be talking virtual
reality with a music star Queen
guitarist Brian May is coming right up
after a roundup of this week's tech news
Apple revealed its new iPhone but there
was a backlash over the decision to
remove the headphone socket the iPhone 7
reused wireless headphones instead the
company says the move took courage we
all knew it was coming but this week
Sony finally announced it to latest
consoles the ps4 pro is a more powerful
version of the ps4 and will have 4k
compatibility and the ps4 slim is you
guessed it a slimmer version and
America's national flight authority is
apparently considering banning Galaxy 7
notes on flights the FAA is reportedly
concerned after Samsung recalled around
2.5 million models because 35 devices
spontaneously exploded
coming up in our games review remember
this we look back at a retro racing
title now I got to sit down with a very
special guest this week he's a music
legend I know that's a term that gets
overused but we think in this case it's
warranted you might know Brian May best
for his guitar playing in the rock band
Queen Bart is also an astrophysicist and
now a tech developer who doesn't love
herself there Brian May has got a whole
youtube playlist devoted to videos of
him filming his audiences with a 3d
selfie stick it's not a gimmick the
guitarist and doctor of astrophysics is
really into 3d innovations
he's even developed his own the Alvear
kit inspired by his love of stereoscopy
a Victorian way of viewing images in 3d
and I designed this our viewer for
Victorian stereo cars and the stereo
cars that I make every day in my life
you know what our stereo car stereo cars
enable you to see something in 3d
instead of flat and it's always been odd
to me and since I've been a kid I wonder
why people don't do that all the time
you know if you can take a stereoscopic
picture something that's 3d and got
depth why wouldn't you do that all the
time rather than just have a flat
feature I had to invent this myself I
mean I didn't invent the stereoscope but
I invented this particular one which
focuses and collapses flat what I did
was design an adapter which is this
little backplate here which fits in and
there's a plate here a metal plate which
attaches to your phone once that's on
there the phone just slips in here and
it's held tight and there's your virtual
reality machine you know it's all fine
stuff but I can for instance take a
picture of you in stereo right are you
ready you can be relaxed but you know
frozen
that's lovely right one and then I move
to the right and take another one
and then this little app will enable you
to slide these things around and sync
them up you press this button and you
have your two pictures side by side put
it in the VR view up and you can see
yourself in stereo or your mates and I
think you'll be shocked and stunned tell
me what it looks like you release this a
few months ago yeah what's the reaction
been like since then actions been great
and the timings really good because we
have a lot of VR stuff coming out from
Queen as well a lot of people must have
asked you this why since I was about 8
years old and I discovered a little
stereo card in a Weetabix packet and I
went wow that hippopotamus looks real
doesn't look flat anymore I just thought
stereo is the way to go
virtual reality is huge right now with
fans spending hundreds of pounds on a
single big-name headset at the budget
end of the market there are options like
Google cardboard so is the owl arrival
to that yeah it is a sense arrival
although I've been working with Google
to make this lovely animation experience
which they've just done for the human
Rhapsody yes you can view it on here or
you can view it in Google cardboard
slightly different geometry slightly
different feel do you think the virtual
reality is really going to stick because
a few years ago everyone said that 3d TV
was the future and man kind of failed
didn't it
I think we in common with the Victorians
liked to have our own experience which
is sort of controllable we like to have
a private world which we can live in if
we want to so I think this is something
which will stay around I actually have a
slight reservation about the 360 thing
because you have to sit in a swivel
chair you see people doing this the
whole time with these things and then we
don't know that kids it's a bit like
watching a 3d TV you don't want to be in
a swivel chair cut off from reality the
whole time you know I don't know what
will stick the most I ever feeling that
the Victorians actually got it right in
the first place
this is what most of us better know
Brian mayors Queen guitarist alongside
Freddie Mercury
we don't thing for one second you step
into virtual reality news who's turning
his back on music he's bringing one of
his latest Jones to 3d viewing people
will be able to sit with their virtual
reality machines and you experience the
concert just as if you were there
suspended in space above the audience
you can look down at the audience and
kind of wave to them and then it will
take you actually onto the stage and
you're interacting with us so something
amazing it is for it and it's something
I dreamed up for a long time next for
Brian he's off on tour to Asia and then
on to another tour in the UK with the
selfie stick though right I'll probably
be taking the 3d selfie stick everywhere
yeah now it's time for our games review
where we take a look at some other
racing titles here's Alyssia to tell us
what takes pole position Codemasters are
one of the UK's oldest studios and
they've been making racing games since
way back in 2009 which in game
development tubs is basically the
Jurassic age f1 2016 is the latest in
their f1 series of racing games and it's
genuinely one of their best to date
they've learned from all the previous
ones and they've created this experience
that's just incredibly realistic
the really interesting thing about this
series of games is that it addresses the
issue that we often forget that races do
professional racing drivers it's not
just about the track it's not about the
tight turns and the glamour and the
glitz of being there on the tarmac it's
also about managing your time your inbox
your agent the engineers and a large
portion of the game is actually spent at
a computer desk which sounds really
boring but trust me if you've ever
played anything like The Sims or
football manager or any of this
simulation game this is right up your
streets when you actually get out onto
the track it is glorious
it's just graphic so slick you could
slip on them
as Jane Austen once said it's a truth
universally acknowledged that a single
player in possession of a good console
must be in want of mariokart it's one of
the bastions of video game gaming
culture we've been playing it since the
90s Mario Kart 64 which is one of my
personal favorites came out in 1996 and
it was one of the first games to really
have 3d graphics and suddenly you had
these 3d rendered graphics that meant
that courses weren't just
two-dimensional we can introduce these
ideas of pets and kind of traps and
really just really engaging courses that
you could really raise it is one of the
first racing games it's just really
creative cartoonish kooky fun it's just
a brilliant game but for those who
worship at the altar of tarmac and who
guzzle their communion wine from a
petrol tank project cars is kind of the
holy grail of racing car simulation
because it's so realistic and this is a
game that's altogether more serious it
came out last year and it there's
there's no poppy soundtrack or generous
rewinds that often racing games have if
you take a wrong turn you can reverse
back onto the tarmac instead project
cars aims to be satisfying in its
realism so if you're the type of person
that drinks your coke full-fat and your
squash undiluted and your moto sports
you like them pure this is definitely
one to check out
well that's it for this week but don't
forget you can watch any of our episodes
on our YouTube playlist just type in Sky
News white and take a look at Sky News
on mobile tablet catch up sky cute and
snapchat for all the latest tech news
throughout the week we'll see you again
next time bye bye